sous les dorures du sénat michèle losier
discute avec un collègue parlementaire
des enjeux du plateau de saclay preuve
qu'au palais du luxembourg le local
n'est jamais très loin surtout pour
l'ancien maire de montigny le bretonneux
et ex-président de saint quentin en
yvelines 78
voilà et là vous avez donc tous les
sénateurs du 78 j'ai des contacts
réguliers avec les maires des six filles
et j'ai bien sûr des dossiers sur
lesquels bien je peux m'investir un peu
plus parce que je les connais puisque
c'est moi que les initiés dont
aujourd'hui on c'est plus facile parce
que avant j'avais certaines barrières
aujourd'hui en tant que parlementaire ça
m'ouvre les portes au sommet de l'état
les portes ouvertes du sommet de l'état
et celle très importante de l'hémicycle
sur le siège 159 précisément dans ma
rangée je suis au centre
voyez dans ce sublime situé au centre
d'un lieu emblématique et historiques ou
ont siégé de nombreux ministres et
président de la république ça vous
permet aussi de penser à tout ce que
vous avez fait pour arriver où vous êtes
tout simplement dont voilà c'est avec un
peu de
fierté effectivement que je me suis
installé dans le fauteuil qui était à
mon nom depuis son arrivée il ya quatre
mois au sénat michel laugier l'ancien
journaliste s'est notamment vu confier
un rapport sur la situation de la presse
dans un contexte de crise seul le
digital montrent de croissance dynamique
mais ils ne représentent encore en
moyenne que ce 1% du chiffre d'affaires
des éditeurs
j'ai procédé pendant plusieurs semaines
à des auditions de tous les
professionnels du secteur que ce soit
des fédérations des représentants de
journaux la presse quotidienne la presse
de province aussi il a donc j'ai rendu
un rapport donc j'ai analysé tout l'air
toute la situation et jeté mon avis sur
le budget qui était proposé des enjeux
d'ordre national d audition de ministre
et l'un des plus beaux palais de la
république
finalement seule la taille de son bureau
rappelle à michel laugier qu'il est un
sénateur fraîchement élu et voilà